it's it's already you know live nation i
think i think it was live nation or
ticketmaster saying
gotta get your vaccine status on your
ticket you want to go to the event
organizer's gonna say they want the
vaccine symbol on you on your on your
ticket
private corporations like walmart here's
here's my prediction
walmart's going to say they're always
taking out you have to wear a mask if
you want to come in
you have to wear a mask you can't come
in you don't wear a mask the videos are
popping up where people are screaming at
other people who are not wearing masks
eventually when the vaccine comes out
they're going to be like you got to have
your vaccine app
you can't come without your vaccine app
you put on your phone you get your qr
code if you don't have it you can't come
in whatever just go get it it's free
it's free the
the government says they're going to
give it to you for free just get it
i i think vaccines are fantastic i think
they're wonderful technology
but i have concerns about this this
culturally mandated medication of people
for sure dude i just saw a commercial
about uh roundup that was monsanto's
flagship oh and it was like
if you use roundup call yeah 16 years
later
they're finding out that it's causing
all this cancer in people now there's
clash
class actually so a rushed vaccine i
mean 10 year what's what about in 12
years how are we going to see some sort
of repercussions i'm not
an experimental rushed vaccine that
big pharma companies are exempt from any
liability from
so so i'm sorry but if you're putting
your full fate into
that that's going to be mandated for
individuals i mean
it's going to be mandated by the
corporations like we saw the ceo of
qantas
recently proposed if you want to fly
you're going to have to have the vaccine
stamp
i mean again there's there's a new study
that that came out that showed that 40
of health professionals in the united
states according to the cdc
are skeptical of this and plan not to
take the vaccine
to be reasonable uh when i traveled to
venezuela you have to have a vaccine
card
because there's like yellow fever and
like you know typhoid and stuff
so you go to go you got to go to the
doctor they give you a card they approve
it you get your vaccinations
i'm i'm i'm down i think vaccinations
are are amazing
we wiped out so many diseases the issue
i have is that if within our own country
you can't go to the store
unless you you have to have some kind of
medication i mean that's crazy
we're not talking about airborne ebola
we're talking about 99.97
survival rate people under 70 are mostly
fine
and they want me to go get you know
medications politicians are saying you
need
this we're going to have the vaccine and
everything is going to go back to normal
that's not how it's going to work this
is again
experimental rushed there's two major
pharma giants fighting for this and if
they get
first to the market they're going to get
record amounts of
profits yeah you think big pharma has a
good record look what they did with the
opioid epidemic
look at medical doctors telling you that
cigarettes are good for you
medical doctors about ddt look at dr
fauci talking about schools
you know look at donald trump saying
early on
the science the science is on our side
which the school should be open
and now fauci is saying oh actually yeah
they were right
don't wear the masks the masks you know
don't worry you're going to get more
sickness
now they're telling you what you need to
wear when mayor gave everybody aids
yes people forget about that bear owns
monsanto by the way what
was that story well they bought monsanto
and now they're a new kind of uh
company that's getting sued to oblivion
because they're finding out that roundup
uh you know was linked to cancer and now
there's major record settlements of
individuals getting millions of dollars
and there's thousands of them coming
forward
with these recorded cancer cases showing
how bayer
lied and tried to cover up the fact that
they knew this was happening and when
they knew this was happening they
continued
and this is the same company that had
medicine that had
what was aids in it that they normally
knew and they said hiv they
continued to sell because they saw the
profits from it
as as less of a liability than actually
stopping of sending this medicine
there's an insane clip
of this happening and now you want to
trust big pharma when they have no
liability with this vaccine and another
thing to really consider here is
from cbs cbs bayer admits it paid
millions in hiv infection cases
just not in english this is from 2011.
whoa to read the english-speaking media
you'd never know that bayer just paid
tens of millions of dollars to end a
three-decade-long scandal in which
the company sold hiv-contaminated blood
products to hemophiliacs
thousands of whom later died of aids i
am not saying
okay i am not saying the vaccine is
going to do anything like this
i am not saying the vaccine is bad i'm
saying in fact vaccines are
awesome there was a very very honestly
it's mandated medication i don't like
yeah you don't even have to you know
make that argument look at how the
government
failed at sending everyone a thousand
two hundred dollars
look at how look at how the government
fails at
the post office the dmv look how the
government fails at basic
human functions look how they can't even
you know set up a lockdown that they
can't follow themselves you trust these
individuals
for your complicated medical process
that's the first ever in its kind
luke i think i think i don't know i
think i think you guys
are over just to too much on this one i
defer no
no i'm not even saying it's bad stop i
defer to cuomo
to kamala harris and joe biden i don't
trust donald trump
i don't trust donald trump to approve
this dude
you brought up ddt a little bit ago that
was can you explain
well before i do that i just want to
make the point the government can't even
figure out how to send you a check they
can't even figure out how to test people
you know they were sending checks to
foreign citizens
exactly that's amazing they can't get
that right they figured out this
complicated
four-layer schedule that people still
didn't get the i know individuals that
still didn't get the checks
and now you trust these individuals to
do a complicated medical listen
they're going to have to do multiple
times listen listen listen
the likelihood in my opinion that this
vaccine comes out
and then we see some like it's either a
conspiracy or it causes widespread
problems i really don't think that's the
case
i think the vaccine's going to come out
it's going to be everyone's going to be
fine why do you think
that like how how how crazy would it be
that like they wrote this vaccine and
then everyone turns into a zombie or
something it's not going to happen
people are going to be fine it's it's
it's it's
you don't know the long-term effects
there was never a vaccine like this ever
in medical history so this is a first of
its kind
new type of vaccine that again we don't
know 10 years vaccination
it's it's really simple as this if you
trust your doctor your doctor knows best
for you
me personally i'm going to chill for a
little bit just like joe biden and
kamala harris and cuomo said
it was cuomo who came out and said i
said that's actually a really good idea
he said i'm gonna wait a little bit
and i was like i trust cuomo on this one
no no you know my plan is
i i think when the vaccine comes out the
first people that need to get it
absolutely this is a win-win case is the
politicians give it
to all the politicians now and now if
they become
sick and something bad happens to them
they won't they won't be
politicians and they're not and then
everything whatever if they're fine
they're not gonna be okay i don't
they're not gonna get sick it's
it's not just it's not gonna happen
they're gonna give it to older people
first
no no they're going to give it to the
people that took the trials first the
the double-blind trials
and then they're going to give it to
medical professionals next right right
then they were saying then once it's
once the the essential workers it goes
to the most vulnerable
i think it's going to be fine i think
we're we're talking about
a covid which has a survival rate of
like 99.9 percent
it's 90 it's 97.5 for people above 70.
we we've i think what what people need
to understand too about
the rapidness of this vaccine trial it's
it's it's bipartisan it's it's i don't
think there's a
look but there's a lot of malarkey
involved do with it as well the placebo
is not actually a salient placebo like
like it's supposed to be it's not
something that
it's it's another vaccine that does have
side effects uh so
again i'm not you might be right you
might be absolutely right i could be
awesome
but yeah but but i think it's this is
this in this case to be skeptical
what i'm i i disagree i disagree i think
uh we'll partly disagree like i said i'm
gonna chill and wait yeah
i was when i heard the democrats come
out and say
this is rushed i was like you know what
if we don't have
unified left and right in this country
saying we reviewed this
there's actually democrats providing the
doubt then i can be like well they're
the ones who are supposed to be cheering
for it
so i'll chill out but here's what i'm
saying we've been developing vaccines
for
a long time we've got a a the
coronavirus
is uh covid is another in the long line
of chronoviruses we've dealt with
i think i think here's what i think i
think it's gonna be fine
i think it's gonna help a lot of people
it could be awesome it's a it's an rna
i just don't like the idea that they're
saying it's a mandate i don't like the
idea that ticket ticket mastered said
we're going to put the symbol on your
tickets well that quantity said you
can't fly unless you have it going to
foreign countries and getting vaccinated
if you don't want to get sick you get
vaccinated but you have to get vaccines
to go to some country for some countries
for some reasons
dude i'm i'm i'm i'm i i gotta i went to
venezuela
and i got like five or six shots i was
there i'm fine i'm trying to find
it i didn't need to do shots so but i
don't know maybe i went later after you
so you went uh i didn't show him a card
i did not i had a vaccination card uh i
would have printed one out
i got i went to the doctor and and and
he was like
we're going to do you know here's how
the the yellow fever one that hurt
yeah it goes sideways into your skin
very slowly because it has to go into
your skin for it to work and i'm like oh
it wasn't that bad subcutaneous yeah or
something like that so that
but but uh this this was this was eight
years ago
this new vaccine is kind of interesting
because the way a regular vaccine works
is they'll inject you with a little bit
of the virus or whatever to get your
body to produce
that's what an accident is well these
new ones don't they don't actually
inject the virus they
make your body think that it has the
virus and then it has the response so it
might be
way safer another has never been a
vaccine for coronavirus
ever sars burrs whatever there never was
so the fact that it's the first ever in
its kind i think
it's skepticism as your best friend i
think taking care of yourself i think a
problem
promo bro you wait listen listen cuomo
said wait and then once it's it goes
through proper approval and you wait a
little bit not only that i'm gonna do a
little bit more than waiting hold on
hold on
you guys need to realize too you're not
getting the vaccine they're not gonna
give it to you we are strapping young
virile men they're not gonna well young
ish
they're not gonna give us the vaccine
anyway so what are you worried about
depends if
we're in the chinese-made fema camps but
do you know about the 1976
wine flu vaccine and that entire fiasco
no uh
people lydia look it up uh the swine flu
vaccine
the the swine flu 1960 um sorry
1976 vaccine yeah that happened where
the government 50 years what was the
situation um
well there was allegedly i don't know
the exact details of it so i don't want
to speak out of hand
but it was another situation where there
was supposedly this this you know deadly
virus going around
the government forced this vaccine which
caused irreversible damage on a lot of
individuals
and then they covered up and lied about
you but do you really
think like i i don't now whether this is
by accident
or whether it's conspiracy we don't know
but i'm saying historically when
something is
first of its kind we don't know what
we're getting into i think it's best
to you've got nothing to worry about you
know why you can you can be skeptical
that's fine i'm totally fine with that
but the first like you mentioned it's
going to go to the people who already
have the trial right yeah then it's
going to go to medical professionals
then it's going to go to the most
vulnerable so you've got nothing to
worry about
and the people who are most vulnerable
got nothing to worry about either
because like a lot of these people are
older already and they're like i could
die from covet or get a vaccine
whatever get the vaccine and guess what
then you'll know
when the older people get the vaccine if
something bad happens because you're not
going to get it for a long time
they were saying on the news that young
people are like they're not even on the
list right now of priority
like people who are under uh i think 50
not even on a priority list at all
yeah because they're like we're not
worried that the survival rate is 99.7
or whatever
once we take care of the vulnerable
we're probably going to be funny you're
probably not going to need
a vaccinated like 60 percent of the
population to have hurt immunity
i think it was 80 i think that was the
exact term but i i look i'll tell you
this i don't trust
big big corporations who are driven just
like
i mean nobody they make profit and they
can't get in trouble for it
for what's that law that got passed that
says the corporations can't be sued for
vaccines well
there's a specific uh order that right
now
vaccine companies when they're making
the coronavirus vaccine there's no
liability
at all they could kill 100 million
people and there's no liability come on
no literally similar laws with other
vaccines
in the united states because they
wouldn't the argument is they wouldn't
produce it if there was too much
risk i just i just maybe it's normalcy
bias
that's it's it's not going to dude i've
heard this crazy conspiracy theory
that hiv was introduced to the
population
mmr vaccine in the 80s have you guys
heard that if we really wanted
to deal with this thing we we would be
talking about zinc
vitamin d sleeping eating a proper diet
exercising but we're not hearing
any of that i'll tell you all you want
vitamin d you want you want to vitamin d
i'll tell you what i think i'll tell you
what i think i don't know what i think i
do i think i think
kovit has a 99.9 survival rate for most
non-vulnerable people most people under
70.
i think they produced a vaccine that was
why was it mass-produced because
it was probably really easy and i'll
tell you the real motive is the vaccine
is going to be fun it's going to be safe
it's going to help the vulnerable
and these companies are going to make
billions of dollars off of something
that isn't as bad as they're making it
out to be
when when they were like oh covet it's
going to be really bad we had we had a
bad covered wave it was really really
bad earlier this year
and then it seems like we kind of got
over it for the most part things are
getting bad now
but now we're getting these weird
stories like where the woman got the
left nostril negative and the right
nostril positive yeah
yeah like negative positive positive
what's happening now is
they're exploiting it the vaccine is
going to be fine because
it's based on technology they're
probably already like i know it's
happening
it's what what's really the the big
concern i have is
guaranteed no bid contracts i am not
concerned about a vaccine
i i'm going to chill out i'm not going
to even get it for a long time anyway
because we're not allowed to get it what
i'm looking at is
the largest transfer of wealth in the
history of the planet the vaccine is
part of that
guaranteed revenue from the government
that's our tax dollars
and printing money devaluing our
currency being sent to big
pharmaceutical companies
the shutting down of our small
businesses and money going to big
corporations
i think the the the arguments about
vaccines and the fear over it is is the
wrong direction
i think you're right about that no no i
agree the largest transfer of wealth
that's happening right now
is the big issue is the big elephant in
the room that people need to
and that's great and i'll tell you what
the problem is when we when people uh
when even we do we talk about vaccines
and we're like oh but these corporations
it's going to scare people into not
taking like not getting
the medication their doctor would
recommend and we want them to do that i
think that's the wrong direction
i think the creep the creepy thing is
our government said
we will guarantee you two billion
dollars if you do this and they're all
just going like
hot dog let's do it our money guaranteed
to them
well people get the vaccine free of
charge sure what's happening is
covid is being used an excuse right now
by a lot of people to destroy the
economy
and this is just one more aspect of
what's destroying our economy you were
saying something about federal reserve
bailouts earlier what was that well
right now when we're seeing uh huge
hedge funds that are connected
to ben bernanke timothy geithner and all
these other top
big bank officials we're we're seeing a
large swamp
of of money that's being sent directly
to them
uh for these larger kind of bailout
packages that have been happening
months ago specifically during the
summer in order to make sure that you
know the stock market keeps going
there's a
huge amount of liquidity just being
directly pumped
into these large hedge funds these large
banks
that again always have their losses
socialized their profits they're
privatized and this has
this is happening on an extreme level
record
number of levels especially right now in
the united states especially with the
federal reserve especially
with wall street banks that are just
literally at the teeth
of the federal government right now
sucking off the wealth of the u.s
dollars so all the devaluation is kind
of getting masked by the shut the
government the
economy shut down so people can't tell
that there's mass inflation from all
this
financial this money if you look at you
know
when you go to the grocery store you see
prices
fluctuating you see prices change and
they have been changing throughout the
years we haven't even noticed it
if you look at the cost of you know
silver a couple decades ago
what it would buy you compared to what
it buys you now there's a huge disparity
there's a huge difference and i think
it's absolutely
clear that what we're having as a
financial economic system is this
fairy tale tale world where there's
a witch behind the screen and it's
literally imaginary make believe land
where we have banksters just pressing
zero
given it to themselves in this private
quasi system
called the federal reserve just
rewarding themselves for absolutely no
reason at all a lot of these people who
are getting money
aren't doing anything they're just
cycling around zeros in their computers
and that's supposedly something that
we're supposed to pay for that's
something that
they're getting profit off of if you
look at wall street if you look at the
larger financial game it is
rigged it is rigged by the very powerful
that are
making money hand over fist meanwhile
everyone else is struggling to survive
and that ponzi scheme that game is
unfolding and it's playing out and
there's going to be some severe
real consequences especially with these
lockdowns especially with these resets
that are going to be astronomical the
rich are getting richer the poor are
getting poorer
to extreme levels where our society is
totally going to be flipped upside down
and it's going to be something that we
have never seen before
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms
for free if you want to listen to us
there thanks for hanging out and we will
see you all
next time
you